سويسرا رسميا محايده ولا تبيع سلاحها
لبلدان غارقه في النزاع لكن فريق تحقيق
اكتشف خلاف ذلك في البرازيل وافغانستان
نظرا لسريه الصفقه التجاريه يكاد يستحيل
التحقيق في شان ساخن كتجاره الاسلحه دون
معلومات مسربه من قبل موظفين ساخطين او
ترحال في ميادين الحب لجا فريق الفيلم الى
استراتيجيه اخرى فدعا ثلاثه محققين خبراء
في المصادر المفتوحه من خلال المصادر الم
فتوح بين فرصه اطلاع الجمهور على بيانات
ومعلومات كانت حتى عهد قريب جدا حكرا على
جماعات لا تدافعوا الا عن مصالحها هو
التحقيق في الحالات او دراستها
اعتمادا على كل ما هو متاح على الانترنت
ويشمل هذا صور اقمار اصطناعيه واي محتوى
غير محظور على الجمهور
السويس ميت
سمولز
ان ريكو
الطائره التي يتحدث عنها هي بي سي 12 ذات
المحرك المروحي الترباني لجميع التضاريس
انتجتها بيلاتوس منذ 30 عاما وراء هذه
التغريده البسيطه يختفي امر جلل احتمال
تورط طائره
في عمليه قصف حديثه في افغانستان على
اليسار مشاهد الخامس عشر من يوليو 2021
نشرها الجيش الافغاني قبل اسابيع قليله من
سقوط كابول وعلى اليمين صوره من صحيفه
ستارز اند سترايس الامريكيه تعرض منظرا
داخليا لطائره بيلاتوس المستخدمه في
افغانستان من المقصوره يطلع الجندي مباشره
على ما تصوره بعد مقارنه شاشتي التحكم
تطابقت كل شيء النقوش على الخلفيه السوداء
وابره شبكه التصويب البيضاء وحتى مواضع
الاحداثيات صادفنا مقالا كتبه ضابطان
امريكيان كبيران احدهما اللواء روبرت
وولترز المتخصص في الاستخبارات العسكريه
وهنا ايضا تفاصيل الشاشه نفسها ووصف دقيق
لدوري بيلاتوس بي سي 12 في قصف نفذه الجيش
الافغاني
طائرات التجسس غير المجهزه للقصف تصور
المنطقه بانتظام تصويرا حيا لمساعده
طائرات اي 29 في قصف الاهداف
يؤكد هذا كل ما تخيلناه كل ما توقعناه من
هذه الطائرات اصبح واقعا تلعب دورا رئيسيا
في تحديد الاهداف وقصفها وبهذا فهي جزء من
منظومه القتل حتى وان لم تكن البيلاتوس
مسلحه واختصرت وظيفتها على تحديد الاهداف
هذا صف اشجار مرئي بوضوح المنظر ضبابي
نوعا ما ولكننا نرى مربعا صف اشجار ومنزل
مربع الشكل في مقاطعه باقصى شمال
افغانستان
في هذا المنشور اكدت وزاره الدفاع انها
قتلت 20 من عناصر طالبان في العمليه ولا
اشاره منها الى اصابه مدنيين لكن سرعان من
انتشرت الفيديوهات على شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي
جثه مشوهه وسوق نسفته القنابل ما هكذا
تكون الغارات الدقيقه فما الذي حدث حقا
يومها في القريه قرر فريق الفيلم التوجه
الى هناك للتحقق فجع عبد الصبور في بنين
خلال القصف احدهما كان مهندسا والاخر
طبيبا وقال انه سقط 12 قتيلا و15 جريحا
بعد تحليق الطائرات روح الطائره بيضاء
اللون تحوم وتحوم فوق المنطقه مده ساعه ثم
سمعنا اجراس انذار وبعدها بساعه ظهرت
طائره سوداء اللون اقتربت الطائره محلقه
على ارتفاع منخفض جدا وقررت المناوره
مرتين وفي المره الثالثه والرابعه اطلقت
اربع قنابل فكيف اجازت سويسرا تصدير
طائرات بيلاتوس المتورطه مباشره في القصف
الجواب بسيط لم يتطلب الامر ترخيصا
بالتصدير ولا رقابه لان طائرات بيلاتوس بي
سي اثني عشر لا تدخل ضمن نطاق القانون
الفيدرالي بي سي 12 لا هي عسكريه ولا
حربيه بل طائره نقل مدنيه يمكن ادخال
الكثير من التعديلات عليها بتركيب اجهزه
استشعار او رسم الخرائط او التدريب او اي
شيء اخر كتيبات بيلاتوس نفسها تثير الشكوك
ففيها نقرا انها متعدده الاستعمالات
كسكاكين الجيش السويسري الشهيره ويمكن
تحويلها لانجاز عدد كبير من الخاصه كتيب
اخر فيه الغموض ذاته ورد فيه الكتلان
يعتبرون بي سي 12 انجي طائره خاصه برجال
الاعمال ما لا يدركه هؤلاء انها معده بحيث
تركب فيها اكثر اجهزه المراقبه والاتصالات
تطورا الاكيد هو ان 18 طائره السويسريه
صدرت الى الولايات المتحده عدلت جميعها
قبل اعاده توجيهها الى افغانستان لست ارى
ما يدعو الى الاستنكار فلو ان بي سي 12 لم
تستخدم لنبت عنها طائره اخرى تؤدي هذه
الوظائف بعد ان بيعت هذه الطائرات يستطيع
المالك الجديد تركيب ما يحلو له عليها
تؤكد الحكومه السويسريه انها ليست عسكريه
بل مركبات مدنيه وبالتالي لا تخضع لضوابط
تصدير الاسلحه وان كل ما ياتي من الولايات
المتحده وينتهي به المطاف في افغانستان لا
يخضع للتشريعات السويسريه غير انه يتوجب
على سويسرا التدقيق في هويه المستخدم
النهائي
صدرت سويسرا 30 مدرعه من طراز بيرانا الى
البحريه البرازيليه هي ليست دبابات بل
عربات معده لحمايه من بداخلها وفي العاده
لا تكون مجهزه ببرج او مدفع الرشاش
للحمايه القريبه
في الواقع اربع وعربات بيران من 30 وصلت
الى هيئه والمفاجاه ان البقيه تجوب شوارع
ريو وتشارك فيما يسمى عمليات التهدئه في
احيائها الفقيره في فيديو الفيسبوك هذا من
عام 2015 تسمع طلقات المدافع الرشاشه
توجه فريق الفيلم الى الموقع للتحقق من
كيفيه استخدام الدبابات السويسريه على عكس
ما سمعناه في سويسرا فان الدبابه مجهزه
ببرج مسلح وليست الوحيده من نوعها كما اكد
الضابط يمكننا استخدام اربعه انواع من
الذخائر على المركبه عيار خمسين وتركيب
12.7 مليمتر بالاضافه الى دمج عيار النيتو
5.56
وقاذفه قنابل من عيار اربعين مليمترا
ونحن نجهز المركبات وفقا لطبيعه الماموريه
استعراض مئات الصور صادف الفريق لقطه
لعربه بيران سويسريه بداخلها رجال في زي
اسود وعلى اكمامهم شعار الجمجمه الذي يميز
تشكيلته
الملقبه بكتيبه الاعدام ولطالما وجهت
منظمه العفو الدوليه اصابع الاتهام الى
هذه الوحده من الشرطه العسكريه في ريو دي
جينيرو بسبب اساليبها الوحشيه والدمويه
تحت المشمع جثه الشاب جيفرسون رودريغيز 18
عاما وبلا سوابق قتله مشاه البحريه على
بعد امتار من عربه
صدقا تخون الكلمات ولا ادري ماذا اقول
بشان حكومه سويسرا التي تبيع هذا النوع من
المعدات للبرازيل ليفرض حكامها سطوطها
فالبرازيليون يعرفون انه سيساء استخدامها
نحن في مناخ حرب اهليه لا تدور بين جيوش
هنا لا يحتاج المواطن البرازيلي الى مثل
هذه القوه العسكريه الباطشه قوات الشرطه
البرا زيليه بقا
للاحاله
[موسيقى]